[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOHN WINSOR: The reason to build this
network organization is that we're
facing a massive tech talent deficit.
In 2020, the research showed
that there were 40 million
more tech jobs available
than there was talent.
And it's predicted in 2025
that will jump to 150 million.
So it doesn't really matter
what size organization you are.
If you're a large organization
that has an amazing brand that
thinks they can hire any
tech talent they want,
or if you're a small startup
that's just struggling to get off
the ground with tech
talent, every organization
is going to have to
put digital technology
and digital tools at the center of their
organization in a post-pandemic world.
We're becoming much more driven by
digital technology, and AI, and machine
learning.
And getting the open talent
to build the right technology
is really critical for
every organization.
[MUSIC PLAYING]